I want to pull up this story from wired
a graphic Hamas video Donald Trump Jr
shared on X's actually real research
confirms a video posted by Donald Trump
Jr showing Hamas militants attacking
Israelis was falsely flagged in a
community note as being years old thus
making X's disinformation problem worse
and not better the first thing I say is
um many of these liberal journalists are
really upset that Elon Musk is doing so
well so any opportunity to attack X is
an opportunity they will take but this
instance it actually ends up working out
Trump Jr is being defended they're in a
weird position where it's like well you
know I guess I guess defending Trump Jr
who's criticizing terror is the lesser
of two evils or whatever in their mind
as leftists it's starting to be as
begrudgingly the lesser of two evils
defending each other as Americans might
be the right way forward this our weird
healing moment so the just of the story
here and what I want to get into with
this is it's it's all fake news and all
manipulation right somebody I I'm not
going to play the video it is it is
beyond graphic it is not can you give a
summary of what it was yeah it's a bunch
of bodies on the ground being shot there
there's it's graphic just understand it
is just I I I I don't even want to
describe it yeah it's people dying and
they're and you're watching it happen
okay it is brutal and uh uh someone
flagged it because they posted a
screenshot saying the video was fake and
from some other time or some other place
but it was a false flag it was a false
likely someone made a fake screenshot
and uh it's really easy to do you can
you can pull up the video on a certain
engine and then you can inspect and edit
the the uh uh the script to make
whatever dates you want to say and then
screen grab it's that easy or you just
go and paint brush and just change it so
apparently wre did the groundwork and
found like no Donald Trump Jr is not
posting fake stuff he's posting real
stuff and it's funny like when w is
defending Trump Jr I mean wow there's
Unity here in this country I guess but I
want to bring up another another uh
tweet here this is something I tweeted
and uh let me see if I can get a bigger
image of this the first image is a tweet
from Andy no where it's a Palestinian
Palestine celebration rally in Dearborn
Michigan where the speaker says when you
go to a black lives matter rally you see
Palestinian Flags when you go to a white
supremacy rally you see Israeli flags
and then a tweet from the ADL white
supremacist leaders are openly
celebrating hamas's attack on Israel
cheering okay you get the point this is
like so much is being exposed here the
lies of the machine are falling apart
the the the the culture war is just
imploding right now and we are being
proven right this right here is one of
the best pro Palestine groups claim
white supremacists love Israel and the
ADL claims white supremacists are
mocking Israel for being attacked yeah
are both true I mean this is nuts yeah
according to the videos I saw according
to the ADL white supremacy has a perfect
ESG score
right so just covering all their bases
yeah exactly and now there are a lot of
people who are outraged that the ADL and
the splc have not condemned black lives
matter as hate groups supporting
terrorism in Israel and and Jonathan
greenblat who is uh the head of the ADL
went on MSNBC criticizing them of their
coverage of this saying because they
were calling it like you know militants
and he's like these are terrorists who's
writing these scripts like bro you
defended these people relentlessly over
the past years and we kept begging you
stop man they're lying and now you get
an overt Act of Terror undeniable like
look I'm seeing Libertarians who are
like no war no intervention being like
yo that was messed up what they did like
wow like this is brutal and now the ADL
nowhere to be found when BLM I'm sorry
dude the ADL is being insulted and
attacked by black lives matter who are
supporting Palestine Hamas terrorists
and they can't even come out and call
them a hate group or or condemn it I
think it just shows exactly what what
these groups represent yeah ADL SMI the
last year telling last many years saying
the worst example of anti-Semitism is
any time you bring up George Soros there
you have it and then now look at this we
have all of it on video and just totally
silent uh I I would like to see the ADL
and the splc publish their article
saying black lives matter as a hate an
anti-semitic hate group you know what's
funny is we've known this yeah since the
women's March yeah when when tablet
magazine published like they're pushing
insane anti-semitic conspiracy theories
and there it is there it is everybody
you know you know here's the
problem this was uh man when was this
this was like six years ago the ACLU
defended unite the right in
Charlottesville saying you have a right
to free speech and then they started
losing a bunch of donors and then all of
a sudden their message changed yeah
money talks yeah it's like like I
mentioned these har Harvard kids who are
like no we didn't mean to sign that
letter in support of Hamas whoops I mean
thec in particular pedals in fear right
they're able to say you know you be nice
to us or follow our talking points or we
will put you on one of our lists and no
one will want to hire you because we'll
try to make it so whenever you show up
you're basically a Google felon I mean
this is how thec keeps its its donors in
check and it keeps its enemies at Bay
because it says we are the author on the
on morality and if we decide that we
don't like you it's all over and the
thing is they are corrupt they don't
have any sort of moral standing to make
that judgment they're just the
institutional power that's there and
when they are needed most where are they
nowhere right theoretically this is the
time that they should be the most
outspoken and instead they're going to
wait until one of their biggest donors
says what they what they want them to
say and then they're going to follow
suit well we need to Lobby uh uh the ADL
and the splc to to put black lives
matter as a anti-semitic hate group on
all of their Pages if they were really
serious about antii you think they'd do
it right away but they would I don't I
I'm questioning their their resolve here
that's fascinating they even list
toas I they do I mean they kind of would
have to right it would be pretty I
didn't even take the check after before
to no they're not working right now
they're not updating anything that's why
there's no that's why there's nothing
they're looking for what Nick ventes is
saying right now they're trying to
change the subject so quickly or again
like I said they are waiting for their
biggest donor to tell them what they're
comfortable with and then they'll abide
by that messaging yeah I obviously have
some some hard feelings about these
organizations but I think they're just
not trustworthy and instead they they
present themselves in ways to ruin other
people's lives and to take money from
people who really think that potentially
they are doing good because that was
that's the hardest thing about all
liberal causes to me there are
potentially people who are you know
compassionate who really believe these
organizations are saying what they what
they pretend they are doing and uh it's
just not the case they're being swindled
exactly I don't know if you ever
experienced this while you were uh doing
your circuits on Fox uh I mean you were
on Tucker show pretty regularly for a
while yeah yeah lots of Fox shows not
just Tuckers yeah but experience what
experience the that you can see there
are people who believe something on the
left really TR really dearly but
ultimately they're being misled oh
absolutely yeah and you can't I mean you
can't be angry at all of them you know
I've got like Democrats in my family
that you know they sincerely believe it
you can't really they don't have any
they're not bad people no but yeah these
these organiz it's not just I mean it's
every organization you can think of it's
like the Human Rights Campaign and glad
for the gay stuff it's you know it's all
trans stuff um but yeah you're
completely right I splc and and L are
pure evil mhm they they they're smear
factories that's all they do yeah and
collect money for it you Semite is uh it
really just means like a a desert person
like someone from Asia and uh East
Africa and it includes Arabs Arabs are
semites acadians canites Hebrews
Ethiopians yes um so like if you hate
Arabs you're also anti-semitic yeah but
that's that's not the idea the ADL has
Twisted it to me no that's not what the
no come on bro people people use words
to convey meaning all right you can't
definitions to control narrative and if
we use if we all understand what the
word means as of today then we can
understand what they're trying to say
when they say it like when when we've
talked about this when the left comes
out and says racism I have no problem
saying they don't mean racism the same
way you do right right we will translate
their version of class and or or
race-based oppression with privileged
groups and majority groups versus
minority groups whereas the right says
Prejudice based on race so
discrimination the definition of
anti-semitism that you that you're
saying that is is Comm
is that it's anti-jewish or is it
anti-israeli is it which one of those
anti-Semitism the common understanding
would be anti-jewish right yeah soti
antire no one no one's saying it to to
refer to Palestinians it's not about
religion it's about where they're from
it's really about where you're from so
by all means you can take issue with the
use of the word Semite in this way but
we know the idea being conveyed right I
do I do but you know that's that's it I
don't know why they hijack the term to
to make I don't who I don't I don't know
that anyone hijacked that sometimes
terms become the like Words happen like
people use words Xerox became a verb
right this is a common thing Kleenex
yeah like nouns be proper names become
verbs because of whatever reason and for
whatever reason for good or bad whatever
your criticism is this is the idea being
conveyed I suppose I bring it up only
because we are in an information war and
it's better to arm yourself with the
knowledge of past definition is that
really ever been a past definition yeah
in 1770 it was created to describe all
those people from that area of the world
yes but anti-semite was that used
colloquially to describe the people of
that world or is it typically just
referred to Jewish people I don't know
let's find out yeah well well you you re
that we keep talking about the news
spread the narrative let us know what
you find out it's you know I I can I can
certainly understand and respect that
there are people who definitely try to
manipulate words to gain power as we see
with the left changing the definition of
sexism and racism and all those things
right but if you're going to be talking
to the average person we simply try to
just understand the ideas that are being
conveyed and then you know push back you
have to go with a colloquial meaning
that makes sense yeah and you can
criticize like I I have no problem
saying like you should use you know the
word Semite refers to many more people
than just Jewish people so by all means
you know you can be more specific and
just say they hate Jews Like that's
actually probably more direct yeah and
you know I think anti-semite kind of
softens the general idea just say they
hate Jews I was listening to One I think
it was a guy from Hamas talking and they
were saying that they wanted to
eradicate uh not not the Jews but um
zionists which is the idea of creating
an Israeli it's a political State it's
not the it had nothing to do with the
religion itself and and it was uh Wicked
Christians so like people that claim to
be Christian but don't believe in God or
don't follow the tenants of the faith
like those aren't real Christians anyway
you guys see what Lindsey Graham said
we're in a religious War yeah do
whatever you have to do level it level
level that place or whatever thanks
lindsy Graham but I bring this up in
response to what you're saying because
you know everything I hear is you know
it was it's the Palestinian people
who've been removed from their homes and
it's like wasn't it like someone else's
before that and someone else's before
that and someone else's before that what
what what did one of our members say
bring back Rome yeah this is the the
real that's why you guys all think about
the Roman Empire it was Ottoman for a
long time and then before that it was
bantine which was like the Eastern Roman
Empire before that it was the Roman
Empire I think Greek for a long time
before that 15 different Alexander
conquered from the Persians I believe
I'm not sure exactly yeah so yeah we're
not in a holy war Lindsey Graham uh
we're not in any War uh firstly yeah we
aren't yeah what a slip on his part yeah
exactly I mean I get like okay so I I'm
the first to admit and acknowledge like
I'm totally an emotional child and being
like Nukem you know but I realize that
that's my emotions and I can't really be
like tweeting and saying that this man
actually you know controls Warbucks and
member of Congress and say with Nikki
Haley she's saying the same stuff he is
right South Carolina like just today
right now I'm having a little bit of
struggle talking about it because it's
like if we were just hanging out the
kitchen table and just I would be like
dark dark dark thoughts because it's war
and we're talking about the horror in
but we're on TV any little idea I have
right now is like could spark conflict
and so I'm like I almost am like
self-censoring for better or worse but I
think we're all feeling that I mean I
think rational people are feeling that
not people who go on who are Senators on
Fox News saying we're in a holy war yeah
I think it's good to be cautious when
you're talking generally I mean I could
understand working out ideas with
friends or people that you trust but in
this case having people like Nikki Haley
or lindsy Graham say you know we are in
a holy war or you know advocating for
more interal Theory you have to remember
that they are sending your family
members to War I mean Nikki Haley does
have a a husband who's deployed to
Africa right now I believe but for the
most part they aren't talking about
things that affect them they are talking
about things that affect more
workingclass mainstream Americans
they're willing to make them make the
sacrifice and I don't know if that's
actually something we should do right I
mean ultimately I know I make this point
when I'm on all the time but the americ
government is supposed to serve the
American people and so even if the the
two countries are having a religious
conflict I don't know that it mean it's
our duty to intervene on their behalf
right like what is Our obligation to our
people first and I don't know that it's
sending young men and women to a war
that we are not necessarily invited to
be a part of even though some some Sid
may want us to intervene when you're a
7-year-old confirmed Southern Bachelor
like Lindsey Graham he doesn't have to
worry about his children being affected
by this yeah I mean he doesn't that's
it's completely right and I think I mean
him of all people yeah and again like
it's it's it's hard to be online right
now I don't know if you feel this way
again but like it makes me more and more
cynical right people who call for us to
intervene or war no one calls for
something that they don't gain from so
what does Lindy Graham gain from this
what does Nikki hilly gain from this
what does Joe Biden gain from this
because the American people lose from us
getting more involved in this conflict
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time